let's bring in michelle turner now
because there is so much harry and megan
news to get to
including the fact that that tell-all
book is already a bestseller
michelle yeah it hit number one in less
than 24 hours kev but the one thing you
won't find in the book
the royals secret move to santa barbara
california
harry and megan's rep confirmed to e.t
they moved into their new family home in
july
nearby neighbors in the beachside
community include sussex pals oprah
ellen as well as kevin costner and rob
lowe the couple who reportedly paid for
their new digs with the help from the
bank of dad
wanted privacy for themselves and little
archie who they've tried to protect from
the paparazzi from the day he was born
presenting archie at windsor castle may
have been great but i think it still
took its toll on the cupboard i mean i
have the two
best guys in the world so i'm really
happy you have to remember that tabloid
coverage
that literally demanded that archie was
presented as soon as possible
there's a line in the book where megan
talks about not wanting to
hand her baby over on a silver platter
to people that have also
tried to take her down through negative
stories there was even more turbulence
surrounding archie's first big arrival
harry and megan abruptly fired archie's
night nurse in the middle of her second
night on the job claiming she was quote
unprofessional and irresponsible other
things we learned inside the pages of
finding freedom
williams first words to megan were i was
looking forward to meeting the girl who
has put that silly grin on my brother's
face
we also found out why megan didn't
attend pippa middleton's i do's
it was all because of this headline it's
megan vs pippa
in the wedding of the rears fearing a
media circus
megan quietly attended the reception
instead
[Music]
as for celeb connections well when
beyonce and jay-z did this
megan's reaction was this big eye emoji
oh and how about h m's three-day
undercover visit to the clooney's villa
in lake como
megan and amal relaxed by the pool harry
checked out george's collection of
motorcycles and even took one out for a
spin
but as royal life and constant scrutiny
became too much for both harry and
meghan there were many tears and omid
was there to witness it all
you you talk about one of the final
engagements that
harry and meghan had when you said megan
began to cry
and that she said she can't believe this
is it i think to see megan so
emotional in that moment and so
vulnerable
just showed how far she felt that she
had been pushed
at that point the couple had really done
everything they could to make it work
[Music]